bat pas on gagne à expert en maladies
infectieuses c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
bankia merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on l'a entendu le ministre
des affaires étrangères qui se veut
rassurant sur la sautée de boris johnson
le premier ministre qui reste aux
commandes qui a bon moral
on nous dit tout c'est la vérité vous
pensé parce qu'évidemment il ya toujours
des des suspicions quand un premier
ministre est hospitalisé bonsoir et je
ne sais pas vraiment je ne saurais vous
dire mais si le premier ministre est
capable de diriger le pays depuis
l'hôpital
alors s'il le dit le fait sans doute
c'est bien vous êtes confiant
comment on réagit justement les
britanniques à cette hospitalisation du
premier ministre boris johnson qui avait
l'air quand même très confiant pour de
prendre beaucoup de distance par rapport
à ceux commis 19 il ya encore plusieurs
jours
il ya effectivement beaucoup
d'inquiétude lorsqu'on sait que même le
premier ministre peut tomber malade
bien sûr nous voulons qu'il se
rétablisse et nous ne voulons que pas
que quiconque tombe malade mais il était
principal c'est que cette maladie peut
toucher toutes les classes tous les âges
tous les groupes
nous devons donc faire très attention à
notre hygiène personnelle et faire tout
ce qu'il faut afin de ne pas être
contaminé
quelle est la réaction des britanniques
justement concernant la gestion de la
crise du gouvernement je le répète on a
vu boys johnson avait pris beaucoup de
distance au départ avec
elle a dit jouan sur l'immunité de la
population ne soit en pas mettre en
place des mesures de confinement strict
est ce que c'est bien perçu aujourd'hui
dans le pays
j'oppose je pense que le concept de
mobilité collective a été mal présentée
je ne pense pas que quiconque voudrait
appliquer des mesures qui mène à
l'immunité collective le pays
s'intéressent beaucoup et très
préoccupée par l'augmentation du nombre
des cas il s'agit du hausse
exponentielle dans le nombre de cas
confirmés et beaucoup de personnes sont
très inquiètes les docteurs à l'hospital
à l'hôpital sont notamment car il ya
beaucoup de patients les gens sont très
inquiets il n'empêche le dit voilà cette
stratégie de l'immunité collective a été
mal expliquée mais enfin qu'est ce qu'il
fallait comprendre alors ce qu'il aurait
fallu comprendre c'est que l'on arrive
après par exemple quelques années les
les gens auraient été en contact avec le
virus serait tombé malade et serait
devenu immunisés de manière naturelle
voici ce qui est effectivement le bon
cas de figure et sachant s'agissant des
collectifs vont pas beaucoup de malades
d'un coup car selon le système de santé
ne peut pas gérer cette situation
justement le système de santé
britannique qu en est-il quelle est la
situation sur place au royaume-uni nhs
renforcer ses capacités dans différentes
régions par exemple à londres au nord et
à l'ouest ainsi que dans l'élite lens
il s'agit de lieux qui sont réservés au
traitement de deux cas de coronavirus
j'espère qu'ils n'auront pas besoin
d'utiliser l'entièreté de cette capacité
mais il faudra voir comment la situation
évolue à quel point l empire lorsque
c'est kim ans et ses nouveaux hôpitaux
sont utilisés alors la situation c'est
aujourd'hui la lé royaume uni qui passe
la barre des 5000 morts de plus en 24
heures selon les scientifiques le pic
devrait intervenir chez vous d'ici à
sept à dix jours est-ce que les hôpitaux
britanniques ont les moyens d'accepter
d'admettre tous les patients en
réanimation à ce qu'il y assez de lits
où est-ce qu'ils vont connaître le
problème qui s'est produit en italie et
aussi en france dans les régions les
plus touchées
je pense qu'ils réussiront à gérer
l'association car nous venons de près
des des lieux provisoire alors que dans
les midlands temps brest etc qui lui
serviront de tampon pour cet afflux de
patients et les personnes qui ont besoin
d'être hospitalisée le sur eux je
l'espère en tout cas
concernant les mesures on l'a dit le
gouvernement adopte est effectivement un
peu tardivement peut-être selon certains
observateurs en tout cas les mêmes
mesures qu'en france et en italie un
confinement on a vu dans les parcs
britannique tout le monde n'avait pas
vraiment respectée ce confinement quelle
est votre réaction c'est pas dans la
nature d aider les britanniques
justement d'obéir à ce genre de
contraintes
effectivement nous sommes très libres 1
et parfois il faut nous ordonner
je reste à la maison pourquoi t'es loi
raisonnables ont été adoptés mais si
elles ne sont pas respectées alors
d'autres lois plus exigeantes ce plus
dures seront adoptées ce qui est
intéressant c'est que chaque loi devrait
être mesurée devrait être juste pour la
population ne vont pas emprisonner les
gens chez eux et ne voulons pas non plus
qu'ils soient contaminés
donc il s'agit de respecter un équilibre
une dernière petite question sur le
discours de la reynière assez court
comment at-il été perçu au royaume-uni
sachant que c'est très rare que l'aco la
reine s'exprime comme ça en public
en effet le message de la reine était
tout à fait pertinent a été très bien
c'est la reine comme je le savais il
n'est pas là dirigeants politiques du
pays
c'est la dirigeante de la monarchie
donne car les gens la respecte
elle est maintenant assez âgées et elles
bénéficient les beaucoup de respect car
elle a vu beaucoup d'événements dans le
pays
grâce à ce très long règne merci bar à
tapas en khâgne un expert en maladies
infectieuses d'avoir été avec nous pour
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir